listen to me i'm gonna tell you right
now
that i also track my qualitative state
of mind meaning right means every single
day
i track i number every day
zero to ten
how i feel about my life work and health
i've done it every year since 2015 and i
could tell you yep
today yeah that in 2020
that i have only had 12 bad days oh
lives
how is that possible what the [ __ ] how
is that possible okay hold on hold on
brian and chris 365.
i've
my dad goes how are you i go the answer
is always terrible next question yeah
yeah yeah yeah but he's had 12 bad days
i have 12 bad days every 12 days
yeah you've had 12 bad days listen to me
why were they bad every bit of time
because i track how do you attract and
buy it down what do you mean yes i write
it down
with this body brian not only do i track
every single
hour of the day as it relates to how i'm
spending the time i track my time so i
could tell you the 250 episodes that i
shot last year of television this year
of television took exactly four percent
of my total life right that's how
optimized it is because i have a choice
i i i design automate and then optimize
all aspects of my life so then i chose
to create qualitative data how do i feel
about my life work and health zero to
ten every day for five years until i got
quantitative things that i could change
and then i changed them over time
to where i never
have another part of my existence that
brings me down because i eliminated it
over time